.
HAKEEM JEFFRIES HAS 200 OTHER --
>> STRAIGHT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>>> YESTERDAY MARKED 11 MONTHS
SINCE RUSSIA'S BRUTAL FULL-SCALE
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
11 MONTHS IN WHICH UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE HAVE SHOWED PUTIN AND THE
WORLD THE FULL FORCE OF THEIR
COURAGE AND THE INDOMITABLE
DETERMINATION TO LIVE FREE.
AND THROUGH EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THIS HORRIFIC WAR, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN STRONG AND
UNWAVERING IN THEIR SUPPORT AND
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS HAVE STOOD TOGETHER.
THE UNITED STATES IS WORKING IN
LOCKSTEP WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS AROUND THE WORLD TO
MAKE SURE THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
ARE IN THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
POSITION TO DEFEND THEIR NATION,
THEIR FAMILIES AND AGAINST THE
BRUTAL, TRULY BRUTAL AGGRESSION
OF RUSSIA.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE LIKES OF THIS
IN A LONG TIME.
THE UNITED STATES AND EUROPE ARE
FULLY UNITED.
THIS MORNING, I HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION WITH OUR NATO
ALLIES, GERMAN CHANCELLOR
SCHULZE, FRENCH PRESIDENT
MACRON, PRIME MINISTER ZANUCK
AND THE ITALIAN PRIME MINISTER
MALONI TO CONTINUE OUR CLOSE
COORDINATION AND FULL SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE BECAUSE YOU ALL KNOW
I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
THE EXPECTATION ON THE PART OF
RUSSIA IS WE'LL BREAK UP.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STAY UNITED
BUT WE ARE FULLY, THOROUGHLY
TOTALLY UNITED.
WITH SPRING APPROACHING
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE WORKING TO
DEFEND THE TERRITORY THEY HOLD
AND PREPARING FOR ADDITIONAL
COUNTEROFFENSIVES TO LIBERATE
THEIR LAND.
THEY NEED TO COUNTER RUSSIA'S
EVOLVING TACTICS AND STRATEGY ON
THE BATTLEFIELD IN THE VERY NEAR
TERM.
THEY NEED TO IMPROVE THEIR
ABILITY TO MANEUVER ON OPEN
TERRAIN AND NEED AN ENDURING
CAPABILITY TO DETER AND DEFEND
AGAINST RUSSIAN AGGRESSION OVER
THE LONG TERM.
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
SECRETARY OF THE MILITARY BEHIND
ME ARE -- THEY'VE BEEN DEEPLY,
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THIS THIS
WHOLE EFFORT.
ARMORED CAPABILITY AS GENERAL
AUSTIN WILL TELL YOU HAS BEEN
CRITICAL AND THAT'S WHY THE
UNITED STATES IS COMMITTED
HUNDREDS OF ARMORED FIGHTING
VEHICLES TO DATE INCLUDING MORE
THAN 500 AS PART OF THE
ASSISTANCE PACKAGE WE ANNOUNCED
LAST FRIDAY AND TODAY, TODAY I'M
ANNOUNCING THAT THE UNITED
STATES WILL BE SENDING 31 ABRAMS
TANKS TO UKRAINE, THE EQUIVALENT
OF ONE UKRAINIAN BATTALION.
SECRETARY AUSTIN HAS RECOMMENDED
THIS STEP BECAUSE IT WILL
ENHANCE UKRAINE'S CAPACITY TO
DEFEND ITS TERRITORY AND ACHIEVE
ITS STRATEGIC OBJECTIVES.
THE ABRAMS TANKS ARE THE MOST
CAPABLE IN THE WORLD AND
EXTREMELY COMPLEX TO OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN SO GIVING THEM THE
PARTS AND TRAINING TO ASSIST
THEM AND BEGIN TO TRAIN THE
TROOPS ON THESE ISSUES OF
SUSTAINMENT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
DELIVERING THESE TANKS TO THE
FIELD IS GOING TO TAKE TIME.
TIME THAT WE'LL USE TO MAKE SURE
THE UKRAINIANS ARE FULLY
PREPARED.
WE'RE ALSO CLOSELY COORDINATING
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT WITH OUR
ALLIES.
THE AMERICAN CONTRIBUTION WILL
BE JOINED BY AN ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENT INCLUDING THAT WILL
BE READILY AVAILABLE IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES.
I'M GRATEFUL TO CHANCELLOR
SCHULZE FOR PROVIDING LEOPARD 2
TANKS AND WILL LEAD AN EFFORT TO
ORGANIZE THE EUROPEAN
CONTRIBUTION OF TWO TANK
BATTALIONS FOR UKRAINE.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHANCELLOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO OUR
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE.
GERMANY HAS REALLY STEPPED UP.
THE CHANCELLOR HAS BEEN A
STRONG, STRONG VOICE FOR UNITY,
A CLOSE FRIEND AND FOR THE LEVEL
OF EFFORT WE'LL CONTINUE
SUPPORTING UKRAINE'S ABILITY TO
FIGHT OFF RUSSIAN AGGRESSION TO
DEFEND ITS SOVEREIGNTY AND
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY, A
WORLDWIDE COMMITMENT.
IT'S A WORLDWIDE COMMITMENT.
LAST WEEK GERMANY SECRETARY
AUSTIN CONVENED THE GROUP FOR
THE EIGHTH TIME.
THIS GROUP MADE UP OF 50
NATIONS, EACH MAKING SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THEIR OWN TO
UKRAINE'S INTEGRITY.
EACH FULLY COMMITTED TO MAKING
UKRAINE REMAIN STRONG AND
INDEPENDENT AND ABLE TO DEFEND
ITSELF AGAINST RUSSIAN THREATS
AND VIOLENCE.
I WANT TO THANK EVERY MEMBER OF
THAT COALITION FOR CONTINUING TO
STEP UP.
THE UK, THE UNITED KINGDOM
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED IT'S DONATING
CHALLENGER 2 TANKS TO UKRAINE.
FRANCE IS CONTRIBUTING AMX-10s,
ARMORED FIGHTING VEHICLES, IN
ADDITION TO THE LEOPARD TANK,
GERMANY LIKE THE UNITED STATES
IS ALSO GERMANY IS ALSO SENDING
A PATRIOT MISSILE BATTERY.
THE NETHERLANDSS IS DONATING A
PATRIOT MISSILE AND LAUNCHERS.
FRANCE, CANADA, THE UK, SLOVAKIA
AND NORWAY HAVE ALL CONTRIBUTED
TO HELP SECURE UKRAINIAN SKIES
AND SAVE THE LIVES OF INNOCENT
CIVILIANS WHO ARE LITERALLY THE
TARGET, THE TARGET OF RUSSIA'S
AGGRESSION.
POLAND IS SENDING ARMORED
VEHICLES.
SWEDEN IS DONATING INFANTRY
FIGHTING VEHICLES.
ITALY IS GIVING ARTILLERY.
DENMARK AND ESTONIA SENDING
HOWITZERS.
LATVIA PROVIDING FOR STINGER
MISSILES.
AND FINLAND RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
ITS LARGEST PACKAGE OF SECURITY
ASSISTANCE TO DATE.
YOU MAY REMEMBER I WAS ASKED A
WHILE AGO WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN AND I SAID, LET
PUTIN KNOW.
HE THOUGHT HE WOULD END UP WITH
A FINLANDIZATION OF EUROPE.
HE HAS THE NATOIZATION OF
FINLAND.
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS WE SENT MORE THAN 3,000
ARMORED VEHICLES, MORE THAN
8,000 ARTILLERY SYSTEMS, MORE
THAT 2 MILLION ROUNDS OF
ARTILLERY AND MORE THAN 50
ADVANCED MULTILAUNCH MISSILE
SYSTEMS AND DEFENSE SYSTEMS TO
COUNTER UKRAINE'S BRUTAL
AGGRESSION THAT'S HAPPENING
BECAUSE OF RUSSIA.
AND, LOOK, TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT
BUILDS ON THE HARD WORK AND
COMMITMENT FROM COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD LED BY THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA TO HELP
UKRAINE DEFEND ITS SOVEREIGNTY
AND TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
HELPING UKRAINE DEFEND AND
PROTECT UKRAINIAN LAND.
IT IS NOT AN OFFENSIVE THREAT TO
RUSSIA.
THERE IS NO OFFENSIVE THREAT TO
IF RUSSIAN TROOPS RETURN TO
RUSSIAN, THEY'LL BE WHERE THEY
BELONG.
THIS WAR WOULD BE OVER TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT, AN END
TO THIS WAR AND JUST AND LASTING
TERMS.
YOU KNOW, OUR TEAMS DO NOT
PERMIT ONE NATION, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ALLOW ONE NATION TO
STEAL A TERRITORY BY FORCE.
OUR TERMS, PRESERVE UKRAINE'S
SOVEREIGNTY AND TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY AND HONOR THE U.N.
CHARTER.
THAT'S OUR TERPS WE'RE WORKING
ON, AND, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE THE
TERPS WE ALL SIGNED UP FOR AND
143 NATIONS VOTED FOR AND THE
UNITED NATIONS GENERAL ASSEMBLY
LAST OCTOBER.
SO, THE UNITED STATES STANDING
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH ALLIES
AND PARTNERS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE.
PUTIN EXPECTED EUROPE AND THE
UNITED STATES TO WEAKEN OUR
RESOLVE.
HE EXPECTED OUR SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE TO CRUMBLE WITH TIME.
HE WAS WRONG.
AND HE WAS WRONG FROM THE
BEGINNING AND HE CONTINUES TO BE
WRONG.
WE ARE UNITED.
AMERICA'S UNITED AND SO IS THE
WORLD.
AND WE APPROACH THE ONE-YEAR
MARK AS WE DO OF THE RUSSIAN
FULL-SCALE INVASION WE REMAIN
UNITED AND DETERMINED AS EVER
AND OUR CONVICTION AND OUR
CAUSE.
THESE TANKS ARE FURTHER EVIDENCE
OF OUR ENDURING UNFLAGGING
COMMITMENT TO UKRAINE AND OUR
CONFIDENCE IN THE SKILL OF THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES.
AS I TOLD PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
WHEN HE WAS HERE AND TODAY IS
HIS BIRTHDAY, BY THE WAY, IN
DECEMBER, WE'RE WITH YOU FOR AS
LONG AS IT TAKE, MR. PRESIDENT.
UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING AN AGE
OLD BATTLE AGAINST AGGRESSION
AND DOMINATION.
IT'S A BATTLE AMERICANS HAVE
FOUGHT PROUDLY TIME AND AGAIN
AND IT'S A BATTLE WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THE UKRAINIANS ARE
WELL EQUIPPED TO FIGHT AS WELL.
THIS IS ABOUT FREEDOM.
FREEDOM FOR UKRAINE.
FREEDOM EVERYWHERE.
IT'S ABOUT THE KIND OF WORLD WE
WANT TO LIVE IN, THE WORLD WE
WANT TO LEAVE TO OUR CHILDREN.
SO MAY GOD PROTECT THE BRAVE
UKRAINIAN DEFENDERS OF THEIR
COUNTRY AND KEEP THE FLAME OF
LIBERTY BURNING BRIGHTLY AS WE
CAN.
THANK YOU.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHY ARE YOU
TAKING THIS DECISION NOW?
DID GERMANY FORCE YOU TO CHANGE
YOUR MIND ON SENDING TANK?
>> GERMANY DIDN'T FORCE ME TO
CHANGE MY MIND.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SU